[Music]
in hard times news oh that's quite odd
is it submitted by Vivian by Vivian
Vivian the person who filmed a viral
video of a man shaving on the train says
he never intended any harm I don't
understand because I didn't see the
viral video on Syria yeah what happened
so I'm not a guy I'm not gonna show you
guys the video brush like a screenshot
of the video what's taking place here is
this guy leaving New York City heading
towards New Jersey shaving on the train
oh wait what's [ __ ] shaving cream
yeah everything and they keep like
throwing the cream on the floor after
she's shaved and he was doing this and
he stood up and he walked out to go to
the bathroom cuz he was even saying like
the bathroom this will work for the mob
or something he's like a gangster yeah
so he's shaving with one of those razor
blades they got a straight edge with no
mirror just hey that went viral so this
limp I'm gonna shave without looking at
it like what if you have a patch of
[ __ ] hair looking like a catfish and
[ __ ] Lance with the shaving cream
healthy view right but you got us to
look in the mirror just don't gotta see
what you're shaving maybe he's looking
at the reflection of the window I mean
there's people that shave in the shower
too oh yeah I'm like how do you do that
[ __ ] I shave in the shower all the time
but you can see Wow Jesse were supposed
to call that out I like your mustache
thank you baby so this man his name is
Anthony and he oh yeah Anthony Anthony
he's 56 years old and so after this went
viral this man was heavily mocked online
like just kind of like the reaction say
you guys just had like what the hell
like this fool they called him a slob I
mean duh Yeah right
okay why is why is the camera guy like
oh I didn't I didn't mean to do it that
way I thought people will feel sorry
like look at this guy yeah what did he
expect you know like everyone's gonna
start feeling sympathy like oh he does
they have a bad
whom to shave and that's why he has to
do it on a train but the train has a
bathroom so it's kind of weird I don't
know he's a little sloppy I mean I would
be okay with it if he was doing this at
the beach where there's plenty of water
I was like he's just going like this and
you'll see Shh or like at the park beep
abducts he did it like I'd be like ok
that's interesting but to each his own
and I'd be alright if you'd like
contained it and didn't inconvenience
anyone right like if he like was doing
this and he had a plastic bag and he's
throwing about different that's weird
but you you took care of it cool do it
but that's almost like vomiting inside
the Train and then leaving you're
spitting at least ya on the ground like
what the [ __ ] that I want to know where
he was going where he had to shave
before he got there maybe was getting
married oh that just tells me he's got a
horrible time management skills
yeah he's fast and he's the dead walking
the daughter down the aisle oh but he
still didn't have time to shave it would
give the night the night shift yeah or
he just grows hair really fast there you
go yeah like his 5 o'clock shadow is
more like a five o'clock Bush I know
damn like a wizard every day I wish I
could do that yes oh this man left after
this went viral and he was being mocked
being called like an animal nasty and
all this thing that's when his brother
Anthony Anthony's brother sorry
Anthony's brother they're both named
Anthony no shoutout for him his brother
that's when he contacted like news
outlets and told them Anthony's story
which was he's actually [ __ ] he's
actually like if you're [ __ ] and
they're able to operate a straight razor
which it requires fine motor skills
that's pretty [ __ ] him you're wrong
on two points what point one he's not
[ __ ] second he wasn't using a
straight razor I was using does their
normal shavers
then I'm not as impressed because if
there's like really the slog yeah cuz if
if you're not all there and you're using
like a dull knife like duh who can't use
a dull knife but if you're not all there
and you're a surgeon and you can do a
good job it's like man that's pretty
amazing
it's impressive cuz it's already hard to
do surgery when you have everything
there yep
but when you're missing half of their
stuff and you're supposed to feel on the
Doosan no shaving equates the surgery
specifically yeah buddy doing it without
like [ __ ] cutting up his a
straightedge
he's like Edward Scissorhands with that
[ __ ] yeah alright so when he was doing
was he was heading towards his brother's
house after spending a few days in a
homeless shelter his brother his other
brother gave him money to buy this train
ticket to go to the brothers house and
to spend the night there and like to try
to get back up on his feet cuz he's been
going through a lot of rough times I
don't know what specifically he's going
from one good brother's house to another
good brother's house no one good brother
gave him the money to go to the brothers
oh yeah it's a one could give him money
the other one can let him stay there
I'll come this guy's like the [ __ ] of
it well what I don't get is like is he
trying to tell the story like look guys
he's homeless so it's like it's like
excuses sloppiness yeah like [ __ ]
laws nasty [ __ ] on the floor for people
to trip and break a [ __ ] arm
that's a good point they don't address
that part the fact that he was throwing
shaving cream on the floor but they they
are just saying like hey don't pass
judgment he spent a few days in the
homeless shelter he was just trying to
look presentable by the time he gets to
his family's house and that's the reason
why he was shaving I don't think
anyone's talking [ __ ] oh yeah tree don't
bring your homeless ways on the [ __ ]
train [ __ ] shaving and throw that
[ __ ] on the floor that's the part that I
think everyone is calling him a slob
that's what I'm saying I don't even
think that's a wholeness way because
I've seen homeless people take full-on
baths in a sink and be decent yeah drive
down I forgot what route it is at our
other office
there's like a community of homeless
people and it's like two rows and it's
[ __ ] so clean like I've never seen
that Street be any cleaner than what it
is that's honest and apart her homeless
singer foods that like the Wakanda of
the homeless community beautiful dude
everyone's wearing glowing purple well I
mean it's probably still just poor time
management right exactly
which probably got him to where he got
on the train yeah cuz time management
skills horrible that's what got him to
become a homeless man was these [ __ ]
shaving and throwing that [ __ ] cuz using
that time to [ __ ] shame he's so
inconsiderate man I think that's what it
is
well the majority of the people while
reading this story don't feel the way
you guys feel because I don't get it you
don't get no sympathy from me that's
like someone taking a [ __ ] on the train
yeah and in there like oh he's homeless
I'm like so he's not exempt from yeah
human like clean human like everyone
else right what does everyone else
saying the reason I'm saying that is
because in two days he they have wreaths
got a go fund me thirty-eight thousand
six hundred eleven dollars for this man
justice you go shame on the train baby I
do that [ __ ] for fun nights damn I mean
congratulations after you shake me
actually give it to him this time yeah
no they they made it clear they were
like we're gonna show receipts that he
receives this and they're also saying
that if he doesn't want the money that
they will donate it to a shelter of his
choice I don't think that's right that's
not right like okay you guys that are
donating money good you want to do
something good in this life that's fine
but I don't think rewarding this guy
which I feel like it is a reward for
being inconsiderate like I think that's
[ __ ] up dude imagine if I was like on
a train and bar was [ __ ] giving me a
haircut and all of my is dripping all
over the [ __ ] it's all over and then
like we leave it there and then people
like what the [ __ ] where all this hair
come from that's exactly what is it rude
or just littering like just littering in
general is [ __ ] rude like we all live
on this [ __ ] planet together like why
are we trying to trash war
or if there's another asian guy standing
on the subway and he's [ __ ] peeing
into a bottle there's [ __ ] piss
splashing all over the place and I'm
like oh don't worry he's mainland
Chinese there no one's gonna start a
GoFundMe for him to [ __ ] get his
manners back just give people a [ __ ]
label and then get sympathy for that
like bad behaviors is bad behavior like
you said if he had a bag and he was just
shaving and [ __ ] keeping it in that
that's fine but if he's going
whoo-whoo-whoo like try to be Picasso
with the [ __ ] shaving cream look like
that's the train that like you're
writing your mom is writing your dog
your feet like like it's a community
thing like why are we rewarding that
what do you think he's super level and
he's very harmonious with the world to
be completely on my [ __ ] mom I fully
agree with you guys in the sense that
I'm like how'd this get 36,000 merit for
saving on a freakin train like there's
so many other people that deserve it
that are decent that work [ __ ] hard
that never inconvenience the world and
they stay in the shadow because they
don't do stupid [ __ ] like this and they
[ __ ] deserve that money I just wonder
what the sympathy angle was for so many
people to want to contribute and see it
in that way
yeah the deed is so it's like this phone
he's homeless right and he's shaving and
causing a mess
and he's given almost 40 G's what
happens if there's a homeless guy that
sees like a grandma come on the plane
and goes oh there's no more chairs left
the plane on the train and he goes I'll
be your chair I'll be a [ __ ] chair
and he's there and the grandma sits on
him right and he's like he's working for
we're gonna give my two hundred thousand
now you know actually he deserves it
yeah the homeless chair yeah it's got to
go viral though it's I'm saying like the
deed it's like if 38 G's is this deed
then we got a spill to scale up and
scale down right and that's let's move
let's let's take a few steps back to you
I think the person recording I mean
putting it on online to this is a dick
yeah it's like that's none of your
[ __ ] business like okay you wanted to
record it show your friends whatever
fine
but when you put it like in a social
platform like that's [ __ ] up like who
are you to put people on blast like
we're always always recording other
people though like people of walmart
like you see all people are always doing
that though I hate that [ __ ] I know if
that's ever gonna stop I like to do it I
hear when I see a character it's like
it's like [ __ ] seen a zebra in the
middle of LA yeah whoa you got an IV
story you know what I mean you see
something weird you gotta like just be
creeper about it what's the weirdest
thing you've ever filmed or require on
the phone I don't do this thing on my IG
story where for some reason I see like
dicks all the time in like different
facets in like different ways
I'm not actual ones just like
visualization yeah I like hash tag like
art is everywhere in my ig story because
and I like draw it out just in case you
didn't see it you know to me uh just
because sometimes like it'll just be ran
to be like you know two sauces and like
you know something to be lying down I'd
be like oh [ __ ] that looks like a dick
and then I'll just make sure that you
guys see it thrown in IG story and just
let people know that I saw a dick today
dudes just the other day I saw this guy
like digging in the trash pull out a
[ __ ] toothbrush and start going a
town and then he was like [ __ ] he was
posted by the lab like the [ __ ]
crosswalk just brushing the [ __ ] out of
his butt yeah that goes through our
trash every day no no there's another
guy we were in Hollywood but he was just
[ __ ] morning routine brushing his
[ __ ] teeth and I was like you know
what I like that he's still cautious
about staying healthy it's gonna snow
that's what I wonder about if like this
is 38 geez what is that in relation to
that should we give back by 12 G's or
give him 500 bucks he's brushing his own
teeth but if he spit it on the floor Dan
you wanna got 40 G's or if he got it
through his waist somewhere
spit it out a bus that's true just
yesterday I was driving I forgot what
area wasn't I think it was like k-town
ash and then this I was at a red light
this homeless dude he had a cell phone
but was broken cuz he crossed the street
to pick up the pieces of his cell phone
and he went back to the bus stop and
then I was like right near him like my
car was right in here and then this boy
he gets up he's like yelling at the car
in the other Lane he was like yelling
this fall he throws the phone again at
that car he hit that car he goes back he
picks it up and when he's passing my car
he kicked my bumper and I honked out of
that like what the [ __ ] and then luckily
it turned green and I ran away just rip
it in the middle of street you should we
got like 50 G's for that yeah how much I
recorded this yeah yeah maybe even 75
G's that one's 38 I had a homeless
person help me out the other day maybe a
couple weeks back and I just parked it
just in close to area Skid Row cuz I had
to go to a building and um his dude
walks up and he's like and you need help
with your parking and I was like like he
was gonna valet it for you yeah and they
do that out there where they just help
you park and then they just like i'ma
watch a car boss yeah and he's like
exactly he's like this is the safest
street out here in LA we make sure you
nee how was your Park know we got the
Magic Man you seen a Magic Man and I was
like nah nursing the management if you
[ __ ] the meter for you yes yes he's
got a [ __ ] forklift our books like
coffee stirrer that's taped to a dime
yeah and he like just stuck in and he
kept on toggling it and then that the
meter would just go up in terms of how
many minutes you just Livi
just pulled it back out that's a good
tip I'm glad you brought up the story
they used to do it with paper clips they
would come up and be like they'll help
you Park and then it's like ghetto valet
dude sometimes they're not even looking
at you they're just like like this and
it's like they do the [ __ ] thing like
an airplane hangar and then you park it
and they come up and they hook you up
don't like it be good for like five
hours and they'll stand there and
they'll watch the car so I'm saying
hundred G's that's worth money right
there
[Music]